but to his teammates
[Applause]
it's the city the kings of English
football again
and this year they're hoping that this
will be the first of a Triple Crown
because gunduan could do what even his
illustrious predecessors didn't manage
and take them to an FA cup and a
champions league as well
[Applause]
but this is some way in which they hope
to
but
a period of grand celebration
which will take them to Wembley which
will take them to Istanbul this is a
huge reward
for 10 months of hard work
that started back in August with that
man scoring a couple against West Ham
that's had its bumps and bruises along
the way but he kept the faith they kept
the faith and Gary they got their reward
now
yeah and they're on the brink of
creating history if they were to go on
and win the FA Cup and the champions
league but as Pep Guardiola said in his
press conference yesterday the Premier
League is the most important trophy it's
the measure over a long season of
whether you're the best and this team
are the best not just this season but
for many many years now and the rest of
them
have got to try and get to their level
because it's very very high
this is a season it's a city there being
crowned Premier League champions for a
third successive season